i knew it was going to kill me it was it
was 11 o'clock i'm watching that
documentary on crack and i'm snowfall do
you see that uh no that's an fbx show on
netflix
no it's a car documentary on crack the
war on drugs
we're on black people no did you call
the war on drugs yeah well crack crack
crack was right
you know cocaine that especially was the
70s
it was actually the uh 80s so cocaine
283 before was uh predominantly a white
drug because it's more expensive and
then crack was the cheap drug
and they made the laws for crack way
worse yeah
so that's what my dad was selling and
black people are coming back so they
went to prison for a long [ __ ] time
yes and
if you had this much crack so if you got
that as a white
kid you you you know hey man don't do
that yeah you didn't go to jail
if you were if you were 22
i remember this so well i remember it so
well my buddy was in jail for a little
bit and i went to visit him
and he said see that guy and i saw this
young like athletic looking black kid
who was like 22.
he was doing a 23-year stretch because
he was selling crack
they made it really hard on black i'm
talking about people people were put
away yeah
for 20 and 30 years 15 years
minimum sentencing rockefeller laws the
judge couldn't the judge literally
couldn't do it again
there was a guideline that's how it was
it was called the war on drugs
and so what happened was you were taking
dads out of the home
you were taking brothers out of the home
where you were taking sons out of the
home
yeah and they they came back and they
and then to add
insult to injury so now you come out and
it's been i don't know
uh 20 years you've got no skills and you
have a felony on your record you've got
a felony
you're not getting housing you can't
even live with your mom no because your
mom lives in a in a project yeah your
mom lives in an association whatever it
is
and they don't want a felon in there so
you can't even live with your mother you
can't live with your family
so now guess where you live on the
street you literally just told my dad's
story
yep well definitely that's literally
exactly everything you just said right
there
i'm sure you try getting a job when you
get out oh my god yeah
he tried to but it was so impossible and
he he wanted to do right because
he wanted to get back in uh into mine
and my brother's uh
life yeah right he was he was trying
real hard but he goes
everywhere was rejecting me he goes but
the only way i knew how to make money
and
you know he goes i you know i'll just
try to do it for a little bit and make
some money
to get him to get on my feet and you
know be back in your guys lives
but uh is that when he got caught he
ended up getting caught
well you go back he did a total he did a
total of 17 17 years gee
warehouse just warehouse yeah and you
can never raise your kids
well yeah the big one a lot of people
aren't well i mean guys it's kind of
getting attention but you know they
passed
uh marijuana in new jersey the obviously
pastor in california arizona
arizona new york's gonna pass it but
what's [ __ ] up with just guys locked
down for
long stretches for marijuana life long
how crazy
for life and it's like so hold on so
you're gonna change the rules
because the economy needs money so you
can change the rules on weed
but then what about these guys because
now you're cool with it and because they
did it when it wasn't cool now they're
they'd lose their [ __ ] lives
yeah and their dads and their brothers
anytime you have a
massive government movement like what
you got to be very careful with these
things
the war on terror that that that war has
been going on for
17 18 years right yeah and iraq
out now to the tune of over 11 trillion
dollars
because you gotta understand say it
again eleven trillion trillion thousand
that's a thousand billion
thousand trillion a thousand billion a
billion seconds thirty three bezos
doesn't have that one billion seconds is
33 years
so if you're real lucky you might lift
three billion seconds if you're real
lucky
usually most people live two billion
because i guess about a thousand billion
a thousand billion so eleven thousand
billion try to put that in my
on the wars the middle east worst which
have been expanded and what happens is
there's money in it there's money
in fighting drugs there's money in
fighting terrorism
and so when you when you label something
war on drugs that war on terror you
better be
you better be very careful and you
better look at who's actually doing the
dying
who's doing the dying it's fine who's
doing the suffering so we always had
conversations about this but
we all can agree that cia put crack or
cocaine
in our neighborhood right uh well that's
what well that's
i don't know i've heard that yeah i i i
don't see
my problem with simplified you got to be
careful also with gone
the cia did it it might have been rogue
elements
so so there are rogue elements in any
group that can make money off stuff like
this
okay i don't know i just know that
cocaine
is big money it is cocaine is big money
and the biggest it's a billion dollar
business a year it's a 11 billion dollar
business a year for the cartel
and you know the number one consumer
america
of course that's right so it's like so
it's a huge market so you like
could we take out the cartel in a week
and release the special force hounds on
them
for sure yeah again it's 11 billion
dollar business yeah and so it starts
from the top though if you want to
eliminate drugs
there's other fires to put out i think
also you've got if you have the big
you're not stopping who
good luck stopping everybody from doing
cocaine yeah
we know this hey have you have you heard
read the book the silk road
no they came out with a movie on it they
said moving on steve he's actually good
friends with the guy
rich or whatever but his concept
i i vibe with i [ __ ] with it so he
started in austin
and he had all these failed like careers
and stuff and he was like what i want to
do
is uh basically amazon for drugs where
it's a safe marketplace
because he believes in you know freedom
of speech everything like you have the
willed if you want to do drugs do drugs
so he he had good intentions but then
and it was all bitcoin so
the way bitcoin works and the way the
silk road work
you couldn't fall you couldn't track it
so you had bad guys
trading stuff on it because start off as
like a community in austin
and they you know sell shrooms and you
know uh ecstasy and marijuana and people
were getting these packages i couldn't
believe it
then it blew up he did interview on
gawker and it just blew the [ __ ] up
and he was making i think they said over
seven million dollars a day
once it started he was making seven
million dollars a day
but uh have you yeah i have a question
but here's the thing so
it's all fun and games but that's just
not the way it works
so you know he's doing now he's double
life sentence
crazy double lifestyle but but then plus
15
but this where he gets dicey and this is
where i mean stevie disagree
stevie's like oh do you really think you
should get live for that i'm like
i don't think he got life for his
business aspirations and
having an open market for drugs he got
life because
as he kept going he was doing murder for
hire he wanted to kill two guys
and there's an informant as a fbi agent
was undercover got on there learned the
system
and became friends with him and was uh
texting like
you know what do you this guy's gonna
[ __ ] us over what do you wanna do and
he's like kill him for me
so they have two
so that fbi agent faked faked the murder
obviously he wasn't really killing it so
he faked it and sent the guy pictures
but that that owner ulbrix uh intentions
he he all for all he knew is that guy
was murdered
even though they're like the murders
never happened i'm like it doesn't
matter
he thinks they didn't order those
murderers
but that's their defense like but they
never no nobody was killed
it's like it doesn't matter his
intentions
as far as he knows have you ever been on
the it's very interesting you're
bringing this up
have you been on the dark web uh no no
no no no
i mean back pain life is dark enough
because somebody brought me on that dark
web
by somebody who's slammed tripoli nope
ari managed this weekend
what would you do by accident uh oh i i
don't want to get into it
it's basically the silk road it's still
going on dude you can order whatever you
want he goes
there's whatever you think is the
economy on
our regular thing because i he goes
there's a there's an economy
you can and i don't know if it's illegal
to even be on there i don't know
no you do ip scramblers he was shown i
said i want to see this he was showing
me
he was showing me like they so that you
have you have to have an ip scrambler
you have to have all this different you
know stuff but there is
a i don't know there's a multi-billion
dollar maybe trillion dollar economy
going on on all the drugs
the darkest arts you can well so so
murder you can watch murder videos
you're a drug dealer
you can have drugs pure drugs sent to
your
home yeah and when something apparently
is sent to your home
you can't get in trouble for it because
you didn't send it as long as you don't
sign the package
yes yeah yeah something like that right
so
i was looking at all i mean and so you
think well you get ripped off
no it's a it's a it's a system where it
goes into escrow the money goes to
escrow like with um
i guess with like a house or something
ebay or something yeah
but there's a middle point you can
murder for hire you got
you know uh beating up people for hire
you got and then you got
apparently and i i you know apparently
the
child pornography on that [ __ ] thing
is apparent it's
so beyond what people realize so it's a
real problem
but have you noticed it's like i i only
heard about it on i think with sam
harris talking about it
like we don't even understand what's
really people don't realize how big
child porn is and like child
sex trafficking it's super big though
yeah but you notice a lot of those rings
and obviously it's barely making dent
but a lot of those drinks are getting
taken out
you see it on the news but they don't
give credit to anybody but it's that
the the epstein's girl who they have in
prison right now
she's telling them who to go after and
you'll notice a lot of them getting
taken out right now yeah is that true
behind the scenes though it's good they
don't
every week someone's getting busted
there are rings it's hurt yeah
rings of people that that communicate
with each other and trade child
pornography and what that means is that
those children are being exploited
somewhere somewhere so
there's a whole system going on yeah but
it's drugs it's weapons
it's exotic animals it's great it's an
entire
ecosystem you got a whole tiger out
there you got everything whatever you
want
it's categories you can even watch
people get killed yeah it's horrifying
well i think about like the like when it
comes like to
jared the fogle the subway dude yeah
like he couldn't be
been the only person the other other
people get caught up with him
they find they they're so they're
they're so you have to show if you want
to be in a group
you have to show a an image of
a you with a child or a some child being
exploited
and it has to be current so you have to
prove that it's current
it's not old that you didn't get it from
something else that you are the one who
originated somehow yeah there are all
kinds of [ __ ]
there are all dif there's world there's
a thing called world market there's
another thing
all different markets all over the place
and i was just like i i
and i said i go am i allowed to are we
allowed to be on this [ __ ] yeah yeah
you're not getting in trouble for being
on there
but and also you have these young smart
younger smart millennials who are doing
this they're they're even
a step ahead of the government as far as
that stuff goes yeah
like they'll catch them eventually but
yeah they're on to the next thing yeah
so was the cartel like that you know
especially when trump was president he
locked down the borders and wouldn't let
anybody come in
they were saying that this detective and
uh feds were saying
no one adapts better than the cartel
like we can shut down whatever we want
they
always always find a way of dabbling and
get drugs through yeah
yeah they're like it's unbelievable like
most don't like we'll take what
cut this leg out from underneath them
and you know they do figure they do all
right and then we take another leg then
they're [ __ ]
cartel we take one leg grows right back
because when you talk about the cartel
you're talking about the highest levels
of government and the military and
if there's that much money if it's a
billion if you're going to make a
billion dollars if i say to you and
you're working in
the government or whatever and i go i'll
give you a million dollars yeah
yeah but the risk is higher but also one
time they get cut
but also think how much money they think
how much money there is and you look at
the big farm
farms the business they're doing the
money they're making so if you legalize
all drugs like
most people agree with then they'd miss
out on that money
so that you know the the dark money of
all that billion dollars
because because the car you want to cut
the cartel's legs out yeah legalize
drugs i think stores popping up and
those cartels are [ __ ]
that's why americans were like we're
just gonna make our own [ __ ] you know
people are gonna get high what
just make them legal make the money and
zone it and tax it
yeah and correct and make money and make
money and bring the economy back but
that's violence
that way as well 100 of course it does
because if you make the penalties that
strong
the people willing to take those risks
are
bad people they're going to kill to get
that you know they they have to enjoy
the dark code of card yeah they have to
you know that's why i got out of the
trade
wait wait wait wait
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just read a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son